[Music]
have you ever wondered which celebrities
are short and which ones are tall
let's find out in a segment called who
tall
i can't wait to find out who's tall how
about you derek i am thrilled amber
well is that a soul patch yes it is
thanks for noticing
you know i have a beard but i've always
wanted a soul patch so i just went for
it and grew it
on top of my beard what do you think i'm
glad you're getting joy from something
you worked hard on
thanks okay so our first celebrity
is tarik where did it go
where'd what go your soul patch
what oh no it got out
got out you just shaved i would never
well then what the hell is going on here
amber did you ever wonder why you rarely
see a soul patch
out in the wild why the only people who
dare grow them are the world's most
skilled and respected artisans
you're michael jordans your stevie
wonders your billy bob thorntons
i've never once wondered any of those
things it's because it takes years of
training before you can just waltz out
of your house with a fully matured
soul patch made a grave error amber
not now wally amber i think you're going
to want to see this
wally it just appeared there was nothing
i could do
my hands were full okay wally don't
panic
i can feel it growing
it's on the move
nobody move
[Music]
it's on your face
[Music]
okay it's done oh right
so now can we find out who tall rupaul
rupaul tall that's all
you